all right stepen Miller Tommy lren thank
you both for being with us on Friday Dr
Phil McGrath he visited the southern uh
Border in Texas meeting with border
patrol officials to witness the ongoing
crisis firsthand he rightly criticized
the administration for their failures
calling it quote a humanitarian crisis
unlike anything we have ever seen before
here with more on his experience
visiting the Border in in Texas uh
author of the book we've got issues our
good friend the host of the Dr Phil
Prime Time show Dr Phil m draw um you
know I've always loved your style which
is just hard-hitting penetrating
straight truth take it or leave it I'm
not worried about your feelings I'm not
sure in this woke world if if that's
quite as acceptable I give you credit
though you went down you went down and
you looked at the border yourself Joe
Biden and KLA Harris can't really say
that they did what you
did well Sean thank you I I did go down
because first off I'm Pro immigration
you you need to understand I I I think
we need immigration in America we need
it for a lot of different reasons but
not the way it's being practiced right
now you're Pro legal immigration you're
Pro legal immigration I'm Pro legal
immigration well and we both are and I
and I know that and I went down and
talked to these gentlemen uh because I
wanted to know from a you know one of
the most psychological principles one of
the most fundamental psychological
principles is you don't reward bad
behavior here and I wanted to go talk to
the guys that are that are heading this
up and I I have to tell you you talk
about some impressive troops down there
these these guys are fighting a morale
battle uh because they can't get what
they need and I wanted to know what's
happening down here what's really going
on you know we hear this number six
million people have come across under
the current Administration I talk to
experts down there that say that number
is a myth that it's closer to 13 to 14
million uh that have come across and I I
asked them straight up what is it you
need here and they I was shocked to hear
them say we don't need more money we
don't need more resources we don't need
more officers we don't need more
legislation we just need the laws that
are on the books to be followed we need
to be allowed to do our job and we can
get this under control right now we
don't need a bunch more money officers
and legislation just let us do our job
that's all we need and if you'll do that
we can get this under control
overnight you know Dr Phil I've been
down there myself over the years
probably 12 15 times horseback
allterrain vehicles on foot uh you know
I I've I've been out I've been in the
drug warehouses you know Florida ceiling
you know drugs that will kill our kids
you know whatever the number is 8
million 10 million when you C when you
count Goda ways uh illegal immigrants
here's the thing nobody else wants to
talk about with supporting legal
immigration that to me means well every
person coming to this country needs to
be vetted they can't have radical ties
or associations we need to know that
before they come here we need to know
give them a health check in the middle
of a post in a post-pandemic world we
need to make sure there won't be a
financial burden on the American people
I think very simple stuff we have people
coming from Ira Iran Syria uh Egypt
Afghanistan China and Russia in L tens
of thousands combined from those
countries why do you think they're
coming to our Southern border and what
are the odds that there are Terror cells
among that that large group of
people we would be incredibly
narcissistic to assume that these people
are coming in here just because they're
in the neighborhood they're coming in
here with an agenda Sean between between
2010 and 2020 it's estimated that 1,00
Chinese came across the southern Border
in the first 11 months of 23 it's
estimated that
33,000 came across and many of them
military AG men now where did they go
once they came across the border we have
no idea they're not being monitored
they're not being followed and look in
China you don't just decide you know
what I think I'll take a trip they have
to go through certain St to get out of
China it costs a lot of money to get
here and when they get here what are
they doing uh if they're working in
farming if they're working in Industry
I'll promise you they are expected to do
certain things are they spying are they
sending uh seeds back from farming to
China are they getting plans from uh
Industries they're working on uh in who
knows what they're doing we don't know
and we need to know and the guards tell
me and I I talked to so many of them
down there they said we're not trying to
close the border what we want to know is
who why and what who's coming in here
why are they coming and what is their
business and we have the right to know
that to control who's coming into this
country and as I said you don't reward
bad behavior you don't subsidize things
that you don't want to see more of but
that's what's happening and there's an
interesting thing that really shocked me
Sean if they run into someone in a brown
uniform that's a Texas Department of
Public Public Safety Border guard they
get arrested they get put in jail and
they get returned if they run into a
green uniform that is uh a a federal
they get money and a court date that's
seven to 10 years down the road and they
get released into the country so you see
these groups coming across and if they
see a brown uniform they hide they see a
green uniform they run towards it and
that to me is just insane that we have
that kind kind of difference going on
down there with guys working side by
side I I really give you a lot of credit
I mean you've spent the time you went
down there you talk to the people on the
front lines mark my words Dr Phil and I
pray to God that I'm wrong that I can
one day say I was wrong among the 10
million or so illegal unvi unvetted Joe
Biden immigrants I guarantee you Terror
cells have mixed among that group and
they're not coming here because they
want a better life for themselves or
their family and and he will then have
blood on his hands that's a national
security disaster a clear and present
danger uh Dr Phil thank you great to
have you back hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else